людині камуфляжі з шевроном
самопроголошеної днр
над лизунова але і чи будемо нас правді
тебе фотографія зроблено здивують і
тисячах кілометрів від донецька на далекому
наприкінці ж люди на кадрі ніколи на
воювала в Україні ті нею постановочні
світла автор наталія скрипка хотіла ви
слова і ти в тому у людей вид війни у
мене це вдома була у мене в мене мета
вдома булата тупості на процес побачивши з
у сида процес баски почну говорив і так
то вина за Україну йому не здається
закуповувала всю нашу росію та novice вечір
вдома на диванах ми все брав і долю там
і все воював і я не за кликаю за
жадібність з турин солдат днр просто чому
мені захотілося а сама мета backpack зад
і потрібного вінс правді ми не майбутній то
чоловік optia pro згуба лижі тому що
нам це пропагували насправді
вина та мер середині нас так куратора
сформулювали тему спеціальну
програма чергова фотовиставкою
офраша
Як вигляд крилася в Москві 15 б різанина для
проекту вигляді брав і світла порубані в
росії за устань ерік аліані українці
біженців аніс свято по поранених
солдатів для дач над на метеликів
по про заявлену тему на виставці не було
фотографій столітті без останнього добра
скарга та вид обох не нас льоткою
фоторедактор наталія ударцева брала
доля у вигляді болю рубає рік у рік все
менше курик ще раз менше самий
так їх на політичну тему фотографії
політичну тему думає
самоцензура норі поза of the rifa рівні
автора можна його тому куратори б вирішила
за сир і так вона тому я кричите
овії продаєте лунатиках емоціях
асоціаціях з правді на виставці ви дну
я політично направо виливається про
конфлікти між людьми жорстоких і траву
який момент і кріс момент атмосфера
списку військові перед варите на
передвоєнну пеклися момент ми починаємо
обидві чувак істерично нервозність я короб
там стоять таким важливим моментом жити та
супер ства дати бовдур пивка ніж
здивувати new женьку так велю ще буду вигляд
бував і сів сирі його жив його
вона вся в телевізорі сіті кого і
безмовно виду тремтіння і моменту су ми не
здається в умовному після завершення
виставкою в Москві та apple омивати
з'явитися і в інших місцях Росії